We first covered space junk way back in December
2012, things have changed around here, but
in space?
They’ve only gotten worse.
There are more than half-a-million pieces
of pieces of space junk floating around above
you, totalling over 7,500 tons [6.8M kg] of
stuff.
It’s not just spent rocket stages, or dead
satellites.
There are bolts, flecks of paint, bits of
shrapnel… and no matter the size, they’re
all going thousands of meters per second waiting
to collide with something important!
Size doesn’t really matter.
There are more than 20,000 pieces of space
debris larger than a softball, but so many,
about 500,000, are just marble-or-larger-sized
pieces.
If any of these hit a spacecraft, they could
cause some serious damage.
So, we have to clean it up.
And when we talk about cleaning up space we
really mean one thing: nudging fast-moving
space debris so it falls into Earth’s atmosphere.
From there, friction with the air will burn
it up or it can fall into the sea.
But that’s not easy.
Any spacecraft planning to de-orbit some junk
will have to: match the target’s orbit,
burn fuel to catch up to the speed of the
junk, then grab it (which could be hard if
it’s tumbling out of control), then burn
more fuel to slow down the now two spacecrafts,
and put them both into a decaying orbit that
will cause the burn up or splashdown of the
junk.
Whew.
The European Space Agency is diving into this
problem headfirst -- launching a new robot
spacecraft in 2024.
It’s called e dot deorbit.
Pronounced e-deorbit.
The ESA’s craft will have a robotic arm
(or maybe a net -- they’re still planning
this one out) and will catch one of their
8-ton derelict satellites.
From there they can slow, redirect and burn
it up.
They’re not the only ones thinking a net
would be the way to go.
A new space-junk-cleaner-upper called Brane
Craft takes this way further.
It’s basically just a membrane of solar
panels and plastic with tiny rockets.
Like Aladdin’s carpet!
The 1-meter square craft is designed to envelop
and redirect smaller pieces of junk.
But you get all that.
The incredible thing is just how thin it is!!
It’s essentially the thinnest possible design…
two special Kapton plastic membranes with
the fuel for the ionic liquid thrusters trapped
in the 10 micron-wide gap between the ‘branes!
The total weight?
35 GRAMS.
They could stack these like pizzas and launch
them all at once.
It’s ingenious.
But of course, is still in planning stages.
Which is why this last one is the most exciting,
for us at least.
The D-Sat is a tiny Italian-made cubesat launched
on an Indian rocket in June 2017.
It’s basically a cubesat with a d-orbit
decommissioning device or D3 on it.
The D3 is like a death engine!
It has independent communications and power
systems and that way sat manufacturers can
slap this little box on their satellites -- pre-planning
for the sat’s death.
Once the sat is dead, the D3 powers up and
sends the craft to Davey Jones.
It’s not a solution to the junk up there
now, but could reduce for future junk.
Of course, these are only proof-of-concepts.
That big ESA mission?
The 2024 launch is just a test… to see if
a net is the way to go, and how best to burn
up the tech… then (maybe) a private company
will take on the challenge!
And let’s hope they do.
There are tons of other plans out there, these
are just some of the more fun ones.
According to Benjamin Bastida, space junk
expert for the ESA: even if we stopped going
to space… in 200 years large pieces will
break into hundreds of thousands of pieces.
This could potentially make space unusable!
Luckily for us, some of the most creative,
and perspicacious minds on the planet are
working this shiz out.
Even if we stop going to space now, we’ll
still have to deal with all this.
So, do you have a favorite plan to stop space
junk?
Tell us about it in the comments.
Did you know Mars could maybe have an atmosphere
again?
There’s a craaaazy NASA plan to do just
that -- watch our video about it here.
I really love this video.
Please subscribe for more Seeker, and come
find me on Twitter to suggest new topics,
or just say hi!